I cannot believe I'm saying this but we
are coming up on episode 10 of our
Jaclyn Hill Saga and let's just say it's
been a journey our girl has certainly
been through the ringer on this and has
shared some very nitty-gritty details
along the way but like any Journey
Japanese experiences have been anything
but linear and after taking a brief
Hiatus from her journey Jaclyn is back
on the horse and running Full Speed
Ahead towards her Wellness goals
especially in light of a big wedding day
ahead as usual there's a lot to unpack
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at Jaclyn's progress update and of
course you can pause the screen or look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating we
will be discussing restrictive behaviors
and also specific calorie counts so
please feel free to skip this video if
it does not support your journey and if
you guys are not subscribed help a girl
out here hit that subscribe button ring
that Bell and don't forget to follow me
on Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen before we get too into the video
Let's play another round of Abby's daily
hunger crushing combo so we're starting
with some overnight oats basically just
some oats have hearts some yogurt and
some milk that I let sit overnight we're
gonna top it off with some banana a
drizzle of peanut butter and one of my
favorites Bill bar chocolate peanut
butter granola bars I am obsessed with
these bars because they taste like
chocolate because they're literally made
with real chocolate but they pack 15
grams of protein so it's perfect in
combination with the fiber from the oats
and the healthy fats in the almond
butter Let Me Tell You Folks this bar
has 15 grams of protein and the Granola
flavor and texture she just hits
different
so if you want to try build bar for
yourself check out the link in my
description and use my promo code ABI
sharp 15 to get 15 off of your order
okay so if you missed my last Jaclyn
video you can check that one out right
here but today we're going to be getting
into Jaclyn's October 11th progress
video titled the best results I've seen
sounds super encouraging so I'm very
excited to catch up with our girl jack
Doritos as you know are my weakness I
cannot say no to Doritos I just don't a
tick tock where I had to put a Dorito in
my mouth I literally didn't even want to
choose not like willpower at this point
I'm like no thank you this in no way is
going to help me reach my goal uh this
is giving Kourtney Kardashian sniffing a
donut Vibes folks having the willpower
to say no to something that you would
like and want shouldn't be a flex and
even if you ate the whole bag of Doritos
never mind just one it's not gonna
completely kibosh your weight loss goals
that all or nothing thinking sounds a
lot like the whole kind of like moment
on your lips lifetime in your hips
Mantra our mothers used to say to
convince us that taking a single bite of
a cookie would instantly cause cellulite
bodies don't work like that folks eating
the foods that we enjoy can and should
be synonymous with our Wellness goals
but to do that we really need to take
them off their pedestal so I think we
just eat the damn Doritos on occasion
and move on I worked out so hard I was
so shaky because that was the first
workout that I had had in a while so
it's not uncommon to feel a little shaky
during exercise as our muscles contract
to support the work we're doing but
excessive shakiness long after a workout
could be an indicator of dehydration or
low blood sugar so it's possible that
Jaclyn's pushed herself like a little
too hard too fast without giving herself
the proper nourishment or hydration to
fuel and recover add a protein shake
protein and water now dinner is teriyaki
salmon with vegetables my brain right
now is in like discipline mode I'm not
trying to like search for a flavor I'm
just trying to put good things in my
body this reminds me of like that gross
nothing tastes as good as skinny feels
adage like it's cringy as [ __ ]
exclusively seeing food as just Fuel and
then intentionally eating foods that are
super Bland or avoid of satisfaction is
something that I see a lot of Fitness
folks do almost in an act to like avoid
overeating something that they actually
enjoy but eating food because you enjoy
its flavor and eating foods that are
good should not be mutually exclusive
finding satisfaction in your food is
really really important not just
psychologically to prevent like
disordered eating behaviors but research
suggests that we may even absorb more
nutrients from foods that we enjoy
versus from foods that we don't and life
is too damn short as for the meal itself
we're getting some Protein healthy fats
and some Fiber no carbs of course which
I'm assuming has to do with Jaclyn's
like one carb a day rule so if that is
the case I would actually rather see her
prioritize carbs after her workout to
help replenish some of those glycogen
stores especially if she's experiencing
chronic shakiness and fatigue
post-workout it's crazy how emotions are
tied to cravings and I got that call
from his vet and it was just so
devastating I have been so exhausted I
cried so much I just want to eat like
pizza like I just want something
comforting there's like this like
sadness in my gut that like I can't feel
with anything else my emotions are
connected to food so we already know
this about Jaclyn given her history with
emotional eating and it sounds like
she's got a lot more self-awareness
around these Tendencies and her triggers
she also is describing what we call
Heart hunger which is when we eat in
response to our emotions even if we
maybe feel physically full and that's
why she feels a bit of a tug of war
where she emotionally wants the pasta
but physically doesn't feel she needs it
this is absolutely normal and these
emotional Cravings also deserve to be
honored guilt-free however if food is
our primary coping mechanism we very
easily disrupt our body trust and our
wisdom so finding new effective
strategies here can be really really key
this ground up chicken with sugar-free
barbecue is really [ __ ] slapping I'm
not eating a carb right now because I
had avocado toast earlier I mean I
wouldn't be happy either if I was eating
a plate full of straight up barbecue
chicken and nothing else overt
restriction often just increases the
likelihood of a binge or overeating and
we have seen this pattern play out many
times over I'm gonna go eat so much
pasta I am done I am so [ __ ] done
those are terrible eating McDonald's
breakfast this isn't even worth the
cheat yeah I'm gonna eat pizza for the
first time in a really long time I'm
gonna eat whatever the hell I want I'm
literally sitting here eating pizza this
is I feel like the world's biggest
failure also I'm about to eat pasta and
I had a piece of pizza
someone come stop me okay but I'm gonna
measure my waist I'm gonna measure my
hips okay measure my arms my thighs
okay that way I can see what's happening
at measurement wise instead of the scale
so Jaclyn's recently made a point to
call out that she's focusing on how she
feels it's not about the way you look it
truly is about the way you feel that's
what it comes down to rather than
aesthetic measurements of success but so
far we haven't exactly seen that play
out and considering how triggering the
frequent weighing was for Jaclyn I'm
just concerned that taking multiple
measurements is just going to do the
same basically accidentally starved
myself and that's never something that I
would want to do I just basically forgot
to eat just like a little protein shake
that's like what nine and 200 calories
and then for lunch all I had was a
turkey burger with scrambled eggs no
carbs whatsoever no vegetables
whatsoever and today is the first day
that I worked out twice in the same day
in years and years and years this is not
good like not good at all first of all
working out twice on a day that you
accidentally starved yourself again
shouldn't be a badge of honor and
honestly considering her vulnerable
audience I wouldn't even publicly
mention this at all listen we all have
days when time gets away from us and
like meals get delayed but one would
think that those are the days that you
also so don't manage to fit in a workout
I'm not really sure how this
accidentally happens like Jaclyn's also
already mentioned post-workout shakiness
on a good day so not eating enough
before and after a workout will only
increase the risk of fatigue injury
muscle breakdown a left light imbalance
and low energy availability needed for
hormonal Health yikes I'm kind of
bothered because it's only like August
3rd and I ate pasta for dinner because
I'm trying not to eat carbs for dinner
like I could eat carbs earlier in the
day because I'm not the person who's
thinking carbs are the enemy but I don't
want to eat pasta for dinner especially
at 10 30 at night ideally I would have
gotten out of the gym and I would have
had a protein shake and I would have had
like a piece of salmon some lettuce when
I say lettuce I mean a full salad girly
your body is in a state of extreme
caloric deprivation carbs are your
friends like any calories are going to
be critical in this scenario whether
it's from carbs protein or fat at now
based on my calculations Jaclyn likely
only ate around 500 calories Max on this
day and she likely needed at least four
times this amount to support her basic
needs and post-workout recovery so
eating a bit of pasta with chicken at
the end of the day is still not enough
to even compensate for the low energy
availability in this day what I don't
understand is if she doesn't think that
carbs are the enemy why does she insist
on restricting them so much when it's
clear that her body so desperately needs
them as usual Jacqueline I feel like we
hear her say one thing and then do
another and if I'm confused I can only
imagine what her young fans must feel
like when watching this I just need to
know because I ate an entire plate of
pasta last night literally 30 minutes
before I went to bed I'm like I'm just
curious what that did [ __ ] I woke up
and went down an entire pound what the
hell one bowl of pasta and we're back on
the scale even though I kind of thought
we'd decided we were past that phase
again our bodies don't look at a plate
of food and decide that one bad food is
going to immediately be converted into
body fat and the good foods are going to
be used up as energy especially given
the caloric deficit that Jacqueline has
experienced on this particular day that
bowl of pasta was literally just a drop
in the bucket also the idea that we
can't eat carbs before bed or can't eat
late at night is a complete myth in fact
research shows that fiber rich carbs can
not only contribute to satiety but may
also benefit our REM sleep quality and
weight gain has a lot more to do with
the total calories we eat versus expend
over time not when we eat them often we
see folks eating large amounts late at
night because they restrict so
aggressively all day and if late night
eating does result in weight gain it's
mainly because we tend to eat more high
calorie snack foods at night when we're
kind of just like too tired to put
together a balanced meal so if this is a
common pattern for you the best way to
squash it is to have regular balanced
meals throughout the day and not to
accidentally under eat so this to me is
a really big win and I did it in a
healthy way and I'm actually taking care
of myself and so this is the first time
that I've been this weight while feeling
good in a very very long time like still
I'm like eating my vegetables I'm not
hydrated I feel like we need a broader
definition of self-care just beyond
eating vegetables and staying hydrated
because this is not enough to support
your needs and well-being I would also
argue that shaking after a workout over
exercising skipping meals living off
salmon and broccoli and not allowing
yourself to enjoy the foods that you eat
is not taking care of yourself yeah this
is not self-care oh what's on the menu
tonight
salmon and roasted right the roasted
roasted I was coloring
and then Jordan made me down this is so
there's nothing like salmon it's cooked
like fresh out of the oven and it's not
like meal prep salmon you know the
salmon veg dinner on repeat is giving me
some major Victoria Beckham PTSD and
while I'm super glad to see that
Jacqueline is actually allowing herself
to derive pleasure from this meal as I
discussed in my video right here eating
the same meal day in and day out really
does limit food variety which not only
can make it more challenging to meet our
nutrient needs but it may also disrupt
the healthy balance of bacteria in our
gut and while eating fish is a great
source of healthy fats and protein
consuming multiple servings or even one
large serving every day can potentially
rack up excess mercury levels beyond
what is considered safe so again
varieties of spice of life I officially
went down to 168 did the math and I
realized I'm down four pounds in one
week now I don't want to diminish
Jaclyn's success here is this is
probably the happiest I've ever seen her
on this journey but my guess is that
this rapid initial weight loss is mostly
just water weight which is what often we
see from a very low carb diet especially
considering how low calorie some of the
days also were often this rate of weight
loss will slow and Plateau which then
typically will impact motivation to
maintain the super low carb low-calorie
diet and then the yo-yo diet cycle
continues now in our last video she
described her goals as no and it's like
it's not like I need this all to get
smaller but I need to get more toned I
need to get more fit for me to feel the
confidence that I want to feel but I
would say that the frequent weighing and
measuring says otherwise but like tell
them like you're like yesterday like you
didn't eat a lot but you felt full
because you ate the right things yeah I
ate a ton of vegetables and a ton of
protein yesterday where I used to be
like I just want the carbs so bad so bad
I don't give anything for the carbs so I
would have like
a little vegetables a little protein and
add that carbon and then I would be
hungry an hour later yeah but now it's
like I just feel good all day
doing the right things I mean it checks
out that Jaclyn feels Fuller from eating
more protein as protein is more
satiating because it delays stomach
emptying and digests slower then let's
just say simple refined carbs also
eating the same combo of salmon and
veggies every single day makes it a
little hard to overeat because it's just
so damn boring and monotonous you're
just kind of like going through the
motions to fill the void but just
because you feel Fuller off of protein
does not necessarily mean that carbs
should be completely eliminated from the
equation for example a meal with a
higher ratio of refined carbs to protein
is likely going to be less satiating
than one that's a little more balanced
same thing goes for choosing high fiber
carbs over carbs that are more refined
ultimately folks carbs are not the enemy
here
and you can 100 still be in a caloric
deficit and lose weight while eating
carbs overall I was really hopeful that
we were reigniting Jaclyn's Journey with
a better mindset but a lot us you know
it feels kind of like business as usual
same scarcity mentality same toxic
relationship with the scale and
measurements same level of restriction
and deprivation and while I want to be
happy for Jaclyn and her progress I'm
not entirely confident that her approach
is one that will support her needs and a
sustainable long term especially since
her version of taking care of herself is
synonymous with limited food variety
over exercising extreme caloric
restriction and cutting out the foods
that she enjoys this is not self-care so
I really hope for Jaclyn's sake that she
stops recycling the same diet strategies
and reaches out to a registered
dietitian so that she can actually get
the support that she needs to thrive and
on that note that's all that I have for
you guys today I would love to hear your
thoughts on who or what you'd like to
see in your view next subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]